doctors are the main hospital in the
eastern city of bene are treating
patients with gadget wounds some were
participating in a protest that was
violently dispatched by Congolese
soldiers on Monday the doctors say
several need emergency surgery
we received seven patients on Monday one
woman was shot in the head and died in
the night three are in critical
condition also in the hospital are
victims of recent attacks by the allied
democratic forces or ADF rebels they've
killed more than a hundred people in one
month and up to two thousand over the
past five years
kuvira la mama says her three children
and three other relatives were killed
during one of the latest attacks her
remaining son was nearly killed - he
tried to run during the attacks but some
of the attackers say they would protect
us then they stopped my husband and
killed him and then our children these
two children watch their parents as they
were hacked to death it's such scenes
that are causing anger on the streets of
Beni protesters accuse a UN mission here
and government forces of not doing
enough to protect them from rebel
attacks the one the UN out of the
regional people have also been
protesting in north key was provincial
capital Goma they say the security
situation in Beni is not acceptable
the Army has warned protesters to keep
off the streets saying armed people have
joined in spoke to the governor who say
the provincial government also has
reports that some protesters are armed
with machetes and clubs to not draw your
vitami Correa we know it has taken a
long time for the security forces to
contain a DF and the group has caused a
lot of harm and it's causing tension
within the population
what protests won't solve the problem
even some politicians are telling the
armed group my my to join in the
protests the only solution is to support
the military but a sentiment by many
protesters is that they won't relent
some Congolese here in Gama are angry by
the military claiming that the protests
in Beni have been infiltrated by armed
people they say the Army is trying to
vilify the protesters and deflect
attention of what is really going on in
that region they say there is genuine
anger and frustration about the state of
security and this is an issue that needs
to be addressed urgently catherine soil
al-jazeera Goma